c'est une grève qui dure depuis l'été
dernier pour cette restauratrice qui a
ouvert son établissement quelques mois
avant le début de la pandémie les
affaires connaissent une baisse
d'activité considérable ces derniers
mois après avoir scrupuleusement
respecté les règles sanitaires dictée
par le gouvernement béatrice a fini par
dire stop la goutte de trop
l'instauration du pass sanitaire devenu
passe vaccinale nous sommes contre la
discrimination
nous avons ouvert un restaurant
justement pour offrir de la convivialité
des moments sympathiques pour les gens
qui viennent manger et nous avons refusé
de faire une sélection sommes pas là
pour violer le secret médical des gens
ne sont pas jean darremont pour demander
la carte d'identité je ne peux assez
remaniée la seule activité que maintient
béatrice c'est la vente à emporter pour
ses clients les plus fidèles séduit par
ses plats traditionnels
c'est tout à fait appréciable parce que
la qualité est vraiment très belle plus
comprendre
l'affolement des gens je comprends leur
souci je comprend un petit peu leur
détresse madame vous allez s essayent de
s'en sortir avec ses plats elle cuisine
très bien et je ne veux pas qu'elle
ferme ses portes à cause de toutes ces
bêtises elle se bat et j'approuve dans
le je veux je veux l'aider comme je peux
et les personnes qui veulent travailler
je comprends pas pourquoi on les a
empêchés de travailler cette géante
compte bien aller au bout de son combat
elle a d'ores et déjà monté un collectif
de restaurateurs en colère et a
déterminé à porter plainte contre l'état
pour atteinte à la liberté
d'entreprendre